hello i'm johnny knoxville welcome to
jackie
three
two
one
and i remember being terrified of
how are we gonna make this a movie i
don't even still barely know how to make
it a tv show like we never got good at
making the tv show you know and uh and
then it was a movie and and we started
to think just like we did on the
beginning of the tv show like well how
do we make it a movie and it turns out
don't do anything different just go
bigger and crazier was all
that was the recipe i remember jeff said
hey man it's not a tv show anymore now
it's a movie it's rated r everything's
got to be bigger and crazier and don't
submit any half-ass ideas and the first
thing that came to my mind i said
how about if i get myself tattooed on
myself larger than myself
which
i don't know if that was even that great
of a movie idea but we did it
and then i said well why don't we shove
a toy car up your ass
and you said my dad won't like that but
ryan will sure do this
well when it was first suggested
uh spike and
jeff suggested it to me i thought what
are we going to have someone play us in
a movie that sounds terrible and they're
like no just make a naughty version of
the tv show i'm like i'm i like that
so uh i was on board after that
what up aaron what's up dude yeah dude
help us crowd brother
um you know i'm pretty happy with the
underwater fart because i recently did
this experiment for youtube where i was
trying to contain fireworks explosion
and i quickly learned that what i was
doing was making pipe bombs and then we
had the same kind of dynamic by trapping
a far underwater and containing that
explosion just a little fart lit with an
underwater torch like it was a blast
that like really rocked my balls like to
think that an underwater fart could be
like such a powerful blast is really
really not just his balls his butthole
too
it's so cool too we shot it on the
phantom camera so you see
every little bit of that percussive
downward nuclear explosion that just
totally almost rips your balls yeah i
mean when you contain an explosion you
amplify it and that's what happened with
the underwater part it was just
absolutely fascinating
and uh triumphant and
i mean that's the one that's just always
going to stick with me for me
the opener of this movie
i mean i it's just it's a no-brainer
yeah it's a no-brainer
there was no brace
so they kept in the movie you physically
had to crawl under the table and hold
them up
and um and then the road we had designed
was a piece of skateboard grip tape that
just had a hole cut through it that we
stuffed your
your wiener and balls through
and then your ball where those hot lamps
get drippy and they started dripping
through that hole and as they came
through the hole they would get sanded
down there there were so many elements
yeah oh god there's so many elements
like with the puppetry the the special
effects
yeah and because of covet no one was
able to get together to properly like
discuss how everything all the moving
parts would work together so knoxville
had to save it by going under there and
holding the balls up i mean look
filmmakers yeah we're filmmakers we make
films yeah you do what it takes you got
to wear a lot of hats in this video yeah
god i i do love the the toy car at the
end of the
the first movie the silence of the lambs
in this movie the high five really
worked in the jackass three it's so
funny because yeah there are those ones
you'll pitch me a lot of times these
cartoony ideas that i have no faith in
like he pitched me the high five the
giant hand that we were hid around the
corner i had no faith in that that that
was gonna work and on the new movie he
pitched me the idea of hiding a bear and
then springing a bear on somebody and i
was like how are we ever gonna do that
bears are loud there's no way to do this
but he just kept pushing and pushing and
finally all right
let's put our minds to it and we figured
it out and to me that's one of the
funniest things and that bit almost went
a little too long with the bear like the
bear got a little
it could have gone really wrong yeah
they're never like being like we better
stop this fair like i remember that too
but i was laughing too hard to actually
say stop so yeah you had no you had no
uh uh real you know you were gonna say
stop i was just glad it wasn't me
[Music]
well when you're hung like pontius
you're going to do the penis stuff some
things just like naturally lend
themselves to certain people yeah like
dave does the poop stuff uh wee-man does
the little guy stuff preston does the
fat guy stuff and when you need a really
smart intellectual scene you just cut to
me behind the monitor
this is gonna be the gnarliest
ever uh
in my jackass career i'm sad to say this
but getting my back tattoo oh yeah was
really really gnarly painful it was like
16 hours all told of just super painful
tattooing on my back and i did not take
it well i actually was there every night
there were four different nights that i
went and uh it hurt so badly this uh guy
who did my back tattoo was um just a
world renowned like like most talented
guy ever and he just hated me he's like
dude i thought you were supposed to be
some kind of a tough guy
like
you [__]
wait do you still have that tattoo
prove it
[Laughter]
yeah dude yeah i did
um for me by far the glove of ants which
is it's like a rite of passage in the
amazon
like boys when they come of age have to
wear this glove full of it's all these
bullet ants that are like sewn or like
stuck into it the bullion has the most
painful sting of any
and or any insect in nature and i'm just
getting some by one sucks but i got
stung by hundreds upon hundreds and it's
the worst pain in my life and it goes on
for like 24 hours and there's nothing
you can do about it and i they didn't
god i had to like i was just up all
night at this hotel in brazil buying my
own ice and throwing in a garbage can
and like laying there
in in um
like until the ice melted don't get
worse i've never seen you it was it was
the worst but it was worse than
everything else combined i want to saw
my arm off you may win the award for
most painful things that sucks it sucked
you know the the bull in this
movie you know i broke my wrist broke my
rib got a concussion and a brain
hemorrhage that was painful but i gotta
say getting pepper sprayed
all those years ago
it's like someone started a fire in your
eyes and tried to put it out with
gasoline it's for 15 or 20 minutes too
nothing like chris had to endure but in
your eyes it did not feel good cover
spray's horrible yeah it sucks
you're getting tired
yeah
you shouldn't drink so much that was a
hard movie to make and i remember when
it got green lit jeff and i walked out
of paramount going
oh god
they just they want the movie geez but
it took it was really hard to figure out
but i'm really proud of what we did and
uh it it
yeah it was a lot of work but i'm happy
how it turned out
cocktail supreme
the giant hand
to me i had no faith in that one and
when i saw it like it was the funniest
thing that we could have just done all
day getting people with that hand giant
so funny yes but the poo cocktail
supreme was
incredible to watch the spectacle of it
and just and the violent and decent
and we didn't know
the gold we had until we saw the
interior cameras which we had no way to
watch until we took them out of there
and cleaned them off and then played
back that footage and that's when it was
like
oh my god concussions aren't great but
as long as you have them before you're
50 it's cool and knoxville is 49.
so we're good
what
used to make us laugh on the first film
we shot that and
then we got to keep upping the bar to
make each other laugh yeah it's the
wrong mindset to think how are we going
to outdo what we just did because that's
that's a dangerous path to go down i
always try to tell these guys all you
gotta do is be funny if it's funny we
win right and what we what makes us
laugh is naturally more outrageous than
what we've already shot so it happens
naturally anyway when you put pressure
on yourself to outdo it it sort of takes
the spirit away it happens in different
directions like yeah exactly the line
moves around like it's not the funny
line is never this it's like oh this is
funny today but man tomorrow that might
be fun you know
[Applause]
can you feel my heart
wow well we've been through so much
together on screen and off and like
our friendship has not only endured it's
gotten stronger nothing is more fun than
making a jackass film because i get to
be with my friends i mean we've been
together for most of the better part of
our adult lives now we're we're stuck
with each other like we are way beyond
friends like we are a family like yeah
it's just so awesome to be together and
inspiring and motivating and when you're
filming a jackass movie you really are
thinking there's no place i'd rather be
yeah it's funny because i like i was a
little skeptical and nervous when we
first got everyone back together uh for
this movie and within five minutes the
magic was so palpable like it was just
so clearly uh oh it's on like even these
new guys fit right in it's just so
natural so and it just made me realize
how much i missed it
you